PROFESSOR: We've briefly
looked at graph isomorphism
in the context of digraphs.
And it comes up in even
more fundamental way really
for simple graphs where the
definition is a bit simpler.
So let's just look at this
graph abstraction idea
and how isomorphism
connects with it.
This is an example
of two different ways
of drawing the same graph.
That is here's a
257, and there's 257.
It's connected directly
to 122, as here.
And also 257 is
connected to 99, as here.
And if you check, it's
exactly the same six vertices
and exactly the
same eight edges.
But they're just
drawn differently.
So we don't want to confuse
a drawing of a graph,
like these two, with
the graph itself.
The graph itself consists
of just the set of nodes
and the set of edges.
And if you extracted that
from these two diagrams,
you would get the
same set of nodes
and the same set of edges.
So same graph,
different layouts.
But here's a case where
it's really the same layout.
You can see these two pictures,
if you ignore the labels,
are exactly the same with the
two grays and the two grays
and the red and the red.
The difference now is that
I've renamed the vertices.
So we've assigned different
labels to those vertices.
And the connection between
the two graphs now,
this graph with vertices
which are integers
and this graph with vertices
that are the names of people,
is that they are isomorphic.
And what isomorphism means
is that all that matters
between two graphs
are their connections.
And so graphs with
the same connections
among the same
number of vertices
are said to be isomorphic.
To say it more
precisely, two graphs
are isomorphic when there's
an edge preserving matching
between their vertices.
Matching meaning
byjection junction
between their vertices.
And edge preserving
means that where
there is an edge
on one side there's
an edge between the
corresponding vertices
on the other side.
Let's look at an example.
Here are two graphs.
And I claim that
they are isomorphic.
On the left, we've got a bunch
of animals, dog, pig, cow, cat.
And on the right we have a bunch
of animal foods, hey, corn,
beef, tuna.
And it's a hint on how we're
going to do the matching.
So I'm going to tell you that
the dog vertex on the left
corresponds to the beef
vertex on the right.
So I'm defining a
function, a byjection,
from the vertices
on the left in blue
to the vertices on
the right in red.
And f of dog is beef.
Likewise, f of
cat, cats eat tuna.
I'm going to map cat to tuna.
And continuing for the
remaining two vertices,
I'm going to map cow to
hay, which is what they eat,
and pig to corn, which is
frequently what's fed to pigs.
OK, so this is a byjection.
I mean, it's a
perfect correspondence
between the four
vertices on the left
and the four vertices
on the right.
But I have to check now that
the edges are preserved.
What does that mean?
Well, let's do an example.
There's an edge on the
left between dog and pig.
That means that there should
be an edge on the right
between where they go to.
So there ought to be an
edge between beef and corn,
because that's where
dog and pig go.
And indeed, there's
an edge there.
So that part's good.
And you can check the others.
The other thing that we
have to check on the left
is since the edge
preserving is an if and only
if, there's an edge on
the right if and only
if there's an edge
on the left, that's
the same as saying there's no
edge on the left if and only
if there's no edge on the right.
So let's check
non-edges on the left.
There's no edge
between cow and pig.
And indeed, cow goes to
hay, and pig goes to corn.
And sure enough,
there is no edge
on the right between
hay and corn.
And you can check
the remaining cases.
These two graphs are isomorphic.
And that function f is in fact
the edge preserving byjection.
So stating it again, an
isomorphism between two
graphs G1 and G2 is a byjection
between the vertices V1 of G1
and the vertices V2 of
G2 with the property
that there's an edge uv
in G1, an E1 edge, if
and only if f of u f of v is an
edge in the second graph in E2.
And it's an if and only
if that's edge preserving.
So if there's an edge here,
there's an edge there.
If there's no edge on the left,
there's no edge on the right.
And that's a definition
that's worth remembering.
It's basically the same
as the digraph case.
Except in the diagram case,
the edges have a direction.
So it would be an edge
from u to v if and only
if there is an edge
from f of u to f of v.
But since we don't have
to worry about direction
in the simple case,
the definition gets
slightly simpler.
What about non-isomorphism?
How do you show that two
graphs are not isomorphic?
I can show you
the two graphs are
isomorphic by simply telling
you what the byjection
between their vertices is.
And then it becomes
a simple matter
of checking whether the
edges that should be there
are there are not.
How do you figure out the
two graphs are not isomorphic
and that there
isn't any byjection
that edge preserves edges?
Well, for a start, these
both have four vertices,
so it's perfect.
There are lots of
byjections between the four
vertices on the left and the
four vertices on the right.
Why isn't there an
edge preserving one?
Well, if you look at
the graph on the left,
it's actually got two vertices
of degree 2 marked in red here.
There's a degree 2 vertex.
And on the right, every vertex
is degree 3, if you check.
Now one of the things that
properties of isomorphism
is that the edges that come out
of the red, these two edges,
have to correspond to
two edges that come out
of wherever it's mapped to.
So a degree 2 vertex can only
map to a degree 2 vertex.
There aren't any.
That's a proof that there
can't be an isomorphism
between the two graphs.
So in general, the
idea is that we're
looking at properties that
are preserved by isomorphism.
This is almost like a state
machine invariant kind of idea.
So a property is
preserved by isomorphism.
Means that if two
graphs-- if graph one has
the property and graph one
is isomorphic to graph two,
then graph two has the property.
And clearly if there's
a property that's
preserved by isomorphism
and one graph has it
and the other graph
doesn't have it,
that's a proof that they
can't be isomorphic.
So what are some of
these properties that
are preserved by isomorphism?
Well, the number of nodes.
Clearly there's got
to be a byjection,
so they have to have the
same number of nodes.
They have to have
the same number
of edges for similar reasons.
Because the edges are preserved.
An edge on one side corresponds
to an edge on the other side.
Others things that
matter is we've
just made this argument
that the degrees
are preserved as a consequence
of the preserving of the edges.
And all sorts of other
structural properties
are going to be preserved by
isomorphism, like for example,
the existence of circular paths,
and distances between vertices,
and things like that.
Those will all be
properties that
are preserved by isomorphism.
So that gives you
a hook on trying
to figure out whether or not
two graphs are or are not
isomorphic.
But in general, there
will be, if you've
got a graph with a few
100 or 1,000 vertices,
there are an awful lot
of potential byjections
between them to check.
And the question is,
how do you do it?
It's a huge search that can't
really be effectively done
exhaustively.
So what you look
for is properties
that are preserved
by isomorphisms
that give you a guide.
So for example, if
the graph on the left
happens to have a degree
4 vertex and that degree
4 vertex is adjacent
to a degree 3 vertex,
then the adjacency of a
degree 4 and a degree 3
is a typical property that's
preserved by isomorphism.
So you know for
sure that if there's
going to be a byjection
between the first graph
and the second graph, this pair
of adjacent vertices of degree
4 and degree 3 can only
map to another pair
of adjacent vertices in
the second graph that
also have degrees 4 and 3.
So that will cut down
enormously the number of places
that this given vertex can
map to in the other graph.
And it gives you
some structure to use
to try to narrow down the search
for the number of isomorphisms,
and where the isomorphism is,
and whether or not it exists.
So having a degree 4 adjacent
to a degree 3, for example,
is a typical property that's
preserved under isomorphism.
But even so, if I give
you two very large graphs,
and these are actually extracted
graphs from some communication
network, an image of
them, it's very hard
to tell whether or not
they're isomorphic.
Well, you could guess,
because of course, we
took the same picture
and copied it twice.
But if there was some subtle
difference between these two,
like I erased one edge somewhere
in the middle of that mess,
how would you figure out
that the two graphs were not
isomorphic in that case?
And the answer is that like
these NP complete problems,
there is no known procedure
to check whether or not
two graphs are isomorphic that
is guaranteed to be efficient
and to run in polynomial time.
On the other hand, there
are technical reasons,
there are technical
properties, that
says that graph
isomorphism is not
one of these NP
complete problems,
unless [? peoples ?] NP
or something like that.
And so that's one distinguishing
characteristic of this problem.
The important one is
that, as a matter of fact,
in practice there are some
really good isomorphism
programs around that
will in many cases
figure out, given two
graphs, whether or not
they are isomorphic in
time that's approximately
the size of the two graphs.
So pragmatically,
graph isomorphism
seems to be a
manageable problem.
Although theoretically
you can't be sure
that these efficient procedures
that work most of the time
are going to work always.
Well, known procedures in
fact blow up exponentially
on some example or another.